українська перемога це знищення
Російської імперії
оцих імперських замашок коли Росія
розпадеться тому що ці загрози мабуть
завжди це знаєш можна тоді вдихнути
повітря посміхнутися і з наступної
секунди почати готуватись до двох
Ну насправді ми воюєм не просто імперію
російською ми воюємо з імперією зла бо
те що вони витворяють знищуючи села
буваючи дітей ґвалтуючи жінок в спалюючи
все на своєму шляху це це зло це країна
яка навіть називається Росія
Російська Федерація але І сьогодні вони
мають це усвідомлювати відповідальність
за те що відбувається сьогодні і на
українській землі по всьому світі Да не
попадає оця сфера інтересів цієї держави
всюди смерть руйнування знищення